the mandoob BR set is a perfect example
of how a simple rule can produce
incredible complexity at its core the
set is generated by iterating a
quadratic equation a simple formula
whose highest exponent is
two to iterate a quadratic equation
choose a value for the variable plug it
into the function then take the output
and feed it back in again and
again the study of how recursive
functions like these change over time is
Central to a field of math called
complex dynamical systems this subject
came about with the goal of
understanding The Real World what are
the mathematics that underly the
physical world that we see most
important early example would have been
the solar system so dynamical systems
that you have some space where you have
some rule that's assigning as time moves
on how that space evolves and how things
move and change in that space